Can you reverse varicose veins?
No, not really. There are some things that you can do from a nutritional standpoint that can
cause give a better tone to Venus structure. I can't think of the nutrition of the top of my head
because it's been so long since somebody asked me about varicose veins.
But there is some nutritional supplements that we used to use way, way back a couple of decades ago.
I think it was a standard process supplement that we used to use. I think it's called
vascular told or something like that. That has helped. Nothing is going to reverse it.
But you can, again, it's a symptom of lots of vascular told.
So I think that's available in the product. They might have changed it right now, but
we used some nutritional products for people who are prone to varicose veins.
And I do remember that people were helped by it, but it's not going to reverse
varicose veins. You can see pre-varicose veins when you start to see
veins come to the surface. But you have veins, you know, closely come to the surface and
pass the surface. And it's going to be very difficult to really help that.
What do I staff just text me? A premier research product called Venomand, the N-E-N-E-N-D
is that's a premier research product that is used for that purpose. Thank you for that.